week from now many students will be home
from their first
day of school hard to believe although
95 percent of students in the clark
county school district decided
to head back to class some were
withdrawn completely
kate houston is live from western high
school to break down the rise in
homeschooling
in our area hey kate
hey yes today western high school is
passing out some chromebooks to students
they're also holding some
athletic practices and while many
families are preparing to head back into
the classroom
some have filed this notice of intent to
home school
instead and one mother that i spoke to
says this was necessary to make sure her
daughters
were getting the education that they
needed really scary
at first the decision is a huge decision
sarah mcduffie is preparing to
homeschool her two
eight-year-old daughters they kind of
got behind last year
and you know it's hard to
teach in a crisis she also worries
mandated masks will create
a difficult learning environment between
all the different things and just being
behind
we really need to buckle down and get
the
fundamentals of school put into place
ccsd says 126 notice of intent
homeschool forms have been submitted for
the upcoming year
that's compared to the nearly 7 000 last
year
i've heard tons of stories of parents
that you know they just kind of tried it
out for one year and then they're like
hey this was a great success like
we'll just keep going with it chelsea
graves helped run a homeschool pod and
is considering doing it again this year
i feel like i was able to target exactly
where they were
and i was able to teach them way more
effectively than i have ever been able
to teach
in a classroom of 30 kids graves says
many curriculums are easy to understand
and can be tailored to their child's
needs
i think the benefit of being the parent
is you know better than anyone how your
kid is going to learn
mcduffie is now connecting with other
home school families to share curriculum
ideas and coordinate ways to socialize
now i'm excited whereas before i was
scared
and anticipating all the work i would
have to do and i just really feel
supported and i'm excited and
i'm glad i have the ability to be able
to do that with my kids
well ccsd requires parents to file a
notice of intent
as well as an educational plan before
homeschooling their child
and homeschooled students can also
participate in activities
sports and up to three classes as long
as their space
and if they meet certain requirements
reporting live from western high school
kate houston 8 news now